hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast simultaneously multi
analytical filing of rare
antigen-specific t-cells with 3d flow
analysis presented by dr. Karen Anderson
and associate professor at Arizona State
University and dr. Doug miner cells a
principal product application scientist
at nano screen
I'm Cindy Valdez of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by nano stream
deanna stream technology is the provider
of life science tools for translational
research and molecular diagnostics the
company's molecular barcoding technology
enables a wide variety of basic research
translational medicine and in vitro
diagnostics application before it again
I want to remind everyone that today's
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice that you
will be proving this presentation in a
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing that presentation use
the support button at the top right or
that Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem good news this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left-hand corner and to follow the
process to obtain your credits without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Karen Anderson and dr. Doug hunter
field I will now turn the presentation
over to our speakers welcome both of you
thank you this is Doug hunter kveld and
as you just heard I'm a principal
product application scientist at naina
string where I focused primarily on the
applications of our 3d biology assays
looking at DNA RNA and protein like you
see here on the screen
and I'll tell you some more about that
banana string has a long track record in
analyzing RNA but certainly we know in
you know that RNA does not really
explain the full complexity of cell
biology so recognizing that we've moved
to adapt our technology to look at a
broader range of analytes so just as a
simple example of why it's important to
look at both RNA and protein in this
study where we stimulated macrophages
and we've done a time course here here
we're monitoring both RNA and proteins
so we can see here for cd4 after you
stimulate the cells you see an increase
in both the RNA and the proteins and
then a concordant down regulation of
both which contrasts to c d9 for example
where the RNA and protein are both
increased after stimulation but then the
RNA falls off but the protein which
we're measuring at the cell surface
remains strongly expressed it is clearly
post transcriptional regulation that's
going on either in the translation or
the transport of cd19 or cv9 right here
so just as another example of looking at
both RNA and protein this is a paper
that was published in 2016 looking at
her - resistance and breast cancer and
they took an approach using publicly
available you know where they looked at
data from TCGA both reverse phase
protein array data looking at some in
this case phosphorylation of GAAP which
is part of the hippo tumor suppressor
pathway and then they looked at that
phosphorylation and they looked at genes
whose expression either correlated or
was anti correlated with phosphorylation
of the app1 so in that way they can
learn a lot more about the biology by
both both looking at protein
phosphorylation and gene expression at
the same time so just in another example
this was a fairly recent publication
from
GSK I believe looking at both
targeted therapeutics and immune
modulators such as pt.1 PDL one ctla4 so
in this study in order to understand
more about the molecular mechanisms of
these commonly combination therapies
they did both RNA analysis by nana
string but then they did extensive
protein analysis using flow cytometry
immunohistochemistry Western blots and
it was really these kinds of studies
that inspired us to create a platform
where we could look at all these
different analytes at one time so doing
that of course requires multiple
traditionally I should say requires
multiple technological approaches maybe
high dupit sequencing mass spectrometry
cytogenetics so imaging type
technologies studies like that are
time-consuming and often quite expensive
may also generate datasets that are
quite disparate in their structure so
it's very hard to integrate those data
they're oftentimes filled with lots of
noise you typically need a team of bios
or petitions and statisticians try to
pull that data together but I think even
more importantly than those two items is
the fact that often times you just don't
have enough sample to look at RNA
protein in other DNA for example from a
very small amount of sample so just to
tell you a little bit about our platform
so on the left here you see the
encounter platform which is our
technology that would use to analyze
will count different molecules within
the cell so we can look at protein we
can look at single nucleotide variants
we can of course do gene expression
which again has been our bread and
butter for many years gene fusions copy
number variation and we have
applications where you can go from
single cells so what are the key
features of this is in it from a single
small sample we can analyze up to eight
eight hundred different targets so those
targets can be again combinations of DNA
RNA and protein but the total number of
analytes is 800 and we do this by
counting molecules the way we do that we
have two parts to our
administering barcode chemistry one is
the barcode itself or the reporter
probes so this is four different colors
in six different positions so by
changing the combinations of those we
can create unique barcodes
and then we have a capture probe here so
if for example were analyzing RNA we
take those probes we mix them with the
RNA the RNA that binds to the specific
target sequences that are designed here
and here and when this complex comes
together we can then count the numbers
of times that that RNA is present in the
sample you'll notice I didn't say
anything like reverse transcription or
PCR so in these applications you're
directly counting the molecules from the
life sample so we image those barcodes
on the system is shown here and so you
can see different barcodes showing up
with different series of colors each
series of colors represents an
individual molecule that we're counting
one of the beauties of ministering is
that the data is very simple so here we
have different sample types across the
top and across the side we have
different analytes and then we're just
simply counting those so we see whole
number counts for each of those analytes
and then we can ask whether that
pardonne protein DNA molecules is
differentially present between the
different samples just by a simple
counting exercise so again you saw there
that with RNA it's quite straightforward
we have the barcode and the capture
probe and we hybridize it to an RNA now
those sequences here and here are
designed to be specific to the RNA of
interest for DNA which we're not going
to talk about in great detail today but
we have applications around typically
around solid tumors where we look at DNA
but really the whole action is right
here so if we have a perfect match
between that sequence and the DNA that
we're interrogating then this complex is
stable and you get a digital count if
there's a mismatch in that region that I
highlight then that complex is unstable
and you don't get a count so we design a
probe to the reference wild-type allele
we design a probe for the specific
mutation that you're looking at analyze
and then we compare the counts between
those and with that technology were able
to identify single nucleotide variants
or small din Dells
when the protein side what we've done is
we've taken antibodies so these are
antibodies that we purchased from
vendors that are well used
we then conjugate some to them a
specific DNA barcode shown here so if
the antibody binds to the sample we have
a unique barcode and then we actually
interrogate that barcode with our
reporter program or capture probe so
we're counting these DNA molecules here
if that DNA molecule exists we know they
have the body balance in the sample we
know the protein was expressed so this
is all an integrated platform where we
can look at DNA RNA and protein all
together at one time get digital counts
for all those molecules on the encounter
system the inputs are very low so for
DNA it's five nanograms of DNA for RNA
it's twenty five nanograms if you're
purifying it or twenty five hundred
cells if you're just lysine the cells
again you don't have to purify the RNA
you don't have to do reverse
transcription for protein so you know it
depending on the assay 250 milligrams or
as it says here down to about a thousand
cells required to look at the protein
analysis for this 3d biology concept
where we're looking at RNA and DNA and
protein is really built on the backbone
of these pan-cancer 770 gene hallmarks
and cancer gene expression series so
these have been out for some time these
are off-the-shelf panels that we provide
with 770 genes we have on the left
apparent cancer pathways which really
focuses on how the tumor starts we have
content related to DNA damage and Contra
kinase and map kinase and that sort of
content in there in the middle we have
the pan-cancer immune profiling which is
really about the immune micro
environment and how the body is actually
responding to the tumor and then tumor
progression things like EMT and ECM and
metastasis and so forth so this panel
has been available for some time and
continue to be available
so another panel that I'm going to talk
about is the IO 360 panel but in order
to talk about that I first want to bring
up something called the tumor
inflammation signature this is an 18
gene panel that looks at different
aspects of immune biology
interferon-gamma biology t-cell
exhaustion and so forth and these genes
have all been known to be related to
response to PD one PDL 1 inhibitor
pathway blockades we have an algorithm
or we can take the digital counts from
these different genes and determine
whether that tumor is in fact
immunologically hot or cold the degree
to which that is true and as you'll see
here and sorry it's a little bit blurry
here but this paper was recently
published by Merck where they did they
looked at interferon gamma related mrna
profile predicts clinical response to PD
1 blockade so it's a great paper there's
a lot of data in there this particular
figure just highlights a comparison of
looking at PDL 1 by i8 C versus 18 gene
some tumor infiltrating tumor
information signature and shows an
increased area under the curve with the
18 gene panel verse the PDL one site C
so improve performance and this was in
head and neck cancer again this is been
published so that tumor inflammation
signature is one part of a larger gene
panel that we've developed called IO 360
that looks at the tumor looks at the
micro environment and looks at the
immune response it's a panel that's
really commonly used in FFPE samples so
it's an RNAi panel so it's enriched for
known and potentially clinically
relevant genes and it is compatible with
the protein with either adding
additional RNA or using our advantage 3d
protein panels I'm not going to talk
about the panels today related to this
which are things related to targeted
pathways like pi3 kinase but it's a
great panel to look at immunological
activity within tumors
to go one level deeper into that this is
another way you can look at the data so
if you take an FFT sample and purify RNA
and analyze it on this sample and the
first thing using this tumor
inflammation signature you can tell
whether the tumor is hot or cold and
then if it is in fact hot you can then
look at for instance pd-1 PDL one
pathway activation only which would
indicate that the the pv 1 PDL one
blockade might be a good option
it may be suppressed so then you need to
activate other pathways so you can see
that here in the inflamed tumor state
and then if it's cold you can look at it
has genes that help you understand
whether there's defect in T cell
trafficking or priming and then as you
see here it goes on and on - then give
you information that would help you
select other types of therapeutic
approaches on that tumor so a lot of
information about therapeutic strategies
that would be used for tumor so I'm
going to jump from that and kind of then
bring it together where we're looking at
both RNA and protein so these are our
Vantage 3d assays so in this one in
particular looking at the immune cell
profiling and signaling assays
so again we're looking at RNA and
protein together the panels that we have
available today are include 778 rnas and
that's that pan-cancer immune profiling
panel that you saw before and then you
can look at that in combination with
either a 30 cell surface markers or 26
intracellular markers you'll see our
typical input is about 20,000 cells but
you'll see as we get into some of the
specific applications here that you can
go down to lower numbers of cells and
importantly you know you can look at the
content and decide that some of it looks
great but you really want to add some
additional content to it that's no
problem
you can send us an antibody we'll add a
custom DNA tag to it send it back to you
you then spike it into the panel so you
can add custom content them to the assay
speaking of content again this is the
RNA panel here and then we have either
that you'd sell profiling or the immune
cells signaling and you'll see a lot of
the players you would expect to see
poppy in the space of i/o pd-1 PDL
ctla4 and so forth and down here these
are intracellular proteins so the way
the standard assay works is very simple
so you take your cells in suspension
some spin those down and collect them
you take some of the cells out and just
like them and that becomes the input for
the RNA analysis again no RNA
purification you just like them and then
if you're doing the immune cell
signaling you fix and perm the cells and
the in cell profiling you just stain the
cell but my cells with the antibodies
again our antibodies have the DNA tag so
after you've stained them wash them
thoroughly to remove any nonspecific
binding and then lyse those cells these
tags are released from the antibodies
you mix that with the RNA hybridize it
to our probes and just count the numbers
of RNA and protein expressed in your
sample so we could talk all day about
validation but I'm just going to show a
little bit of data here and this is
stimulating cells over a time course
with PMA and in this case we're looking
at PDL one and showing changes in a
sample that's been either stimulated
treated or untreated and showing an
increase in fluorescence here with the
treated sample as you would expect so
just another way to look at that here is
mean fluorescence intensity and showing
with the treated sample the increase in
expression and the untreated no increase
in expression so here we're looking at
more markers and just PDL one we're
looking at in three other markers and
you can see comparing the mean
fluorescence intensity to the digital
counting from our nano string 3d assay
you get very much the same response but
importantly you're getting the RNA data
as well and this is where you really
start to see some interesting results
right another example where the RNA goes
up along with the protein but then the
RNA is stabilized or even going down the
protein continues to be expressed at a
higher level on the cell surface so
seeing some just coordinates and really
showing the value of looking at both RNA
and protein one of the applications of
this has been in adoptive T cell therapy
of which
party cell therapy is one of the most
common and it's an area where there is a
great need to improve it to identify
biomarkers to understand efficacy and
reduce toxic toxicity so one of the
areas in an early study we've done with
a leading company in this space is
looking particularly at biomarkers to
characterize t-cell function and
production so you've taken the the
patient sample you purified the t-cells
you've engineered the t-cells to express
a chimeric antigen receptor and then
before you put those back into the
patient that sure would be nice to know
whether that P cell is going to be a
highly functioning t-cell and is
actually going to have the the targeted
cytotoxic activity that you are hoping
for so the way that these experiments
were done was taking the car T cell and
then incubating that Co incubating the
car T cell with SL beaver expresses the
specific target for the car or a
nonspecific target and so in this case
we hope with the specific target we hope
to see a strong cytotoxic activity of
the car T cells and then not with the
nonspecific target and essentially
that's what we see here we're looking at
770 RNAs and 30 proteins using our
immune cell profiling and we have the
car T cells with a specific target or
the nonspecific target and we can see
very strong differences in the
expression which will help heart some
collaborators here learn more about the
biology of their car T cells with
respect to this they're getting their
specific target so really what they want
to know is they want to know how does
this relate to clinical outcome and so
I'm just in a very small pilot study
we've started to look at that
so from same starting data set RNA and
protein in comparing those patients the
samples from the patients that were non
responders first responders and starting
to see a difference these are
statistically different differentially
expressed RNAs and proteins in the assay
between the non responders and the
responders now if you recall the assay
going in at 30 proteins in 770 RNAs but
what we actually see is that there's
five proteins in 20
rnase that start to make up a sort of a
candidate signature that these that our
collaborator is going to go on to
continue to pursue and refine come
towards clinical application a really
great example of using the 3d biology
technology in this case starting with
you know a partially purified clinical
sample going right into our assay and
then seeing changes in gene and protein
expression we also pretty quickly
realized from talking to customers that
there was an interest in integrating
that with flow cytometry to look at very
specific populations ourselves so the
idea being we call this 3d flow the idea
being is at understanding the function
of specific immune cell populations and
disease or therapeutic response requires
sophisticated analytical methods and
that those methods are complex
oftentimes inefficient or costly so you
might be combining with high parameter
flows analytical cytometry or site op
analysis with sorting specific
populations of cells and doing nano
string or qPCR RNA see you're using
multiple technologies to look at these
and again oftentimes you don't
necessarily have a lot of sample but you
know that the target population the
cells you want to look at which might be
quite rare so 3d flow expands on
existing flow cytometry methods to
enable a deep analysis of defined cell
populations again with the goal to
discover biomarkers or therapeutic
targets for IO autoimmune disease or or
any area in which the immune cell is of
particular interest so the way this
athlete works is you know the cell
population do you want to go after so
maybe you want to go after T regs or you
want to go after as well here antigen
specific T cells so you stay in the cell
with standard flow cytometry antibodies
that are fluorescently labeled to sort
the populations of interest but at the
same time you're standing those cells
with our DNA labeled antibody cocktail
which has 30 cell surface proteins you
can sort the cells based on the
fluorescent markers lyse the cells like
I've described which releases the RNA
and the protein tags and they hybridize
together and then you're able to
characterize
the RNA and protein from those
populations of cells of which you were
interested
so our content from the protein side
this is another look at it we looking at
it before has a lot of excellent content
for t-cell profiling so it has content
related to sort of t-cell general T cell
biology activation inhibition and so
you'll see with some more information
there of course all this information the
content the clones everything is
available so you can peruse to that and
again if you see if there's anything
missing we can add content to be so we
can add custom content again just
another look at it here we're starting
with a larger t-cell population we're
then sorting specific T cells they're
stained with our DNA label they other
bodies and we're able to characterize
the expression of all these antibodies
in those rare populations of cells so
you might be asking about the underlying
biology these cells they're in an
exhausted state or an activated state
how those T cells change before and
after immunotherapy so you may be
engaging the target on the T cell and
you may or may not see response in the
patient so if you really want to
understand what's going on the pad T
cell when you have response to the in a
patient or lack of response this is a
great approach to dig right in and
interrogate those T cells so this is you
know again how the system works you
stain the cells with the fluorescent
markers we see the fluorescence here
with the CA 3 positive T cells the cd19
positive B cells and then the cd8
seeding threes but each one of these
cells each one of these spots is also
coated with DNA labeled antibodies which
at this point you don't see but if we
sort these different for different
populations and we sort either 5,000 of
those cells or 500 of those cells we get
data that looks like this so each one of
these spots is a is the normalized
digital counts for one of the 30
proteins in our assay so we sort Eva
5,000 cells or 500 cells and what we see
is we get a very high correlation and
what this
tells us that the BSA is clearly
sensitive down to 500 cells for protein
analysis specifically and we repeat this
with cd4 cd8 cd3 in the cd19 positive
b-cells so very reproducible very
sensitive for very small numbers
ourselves and again this is looking at
those 30 protein markers alone so
another way to look at that is um here
we have our cd4s at the different
populations cd3 cd8 and c 19 and this
has been a heat map showing the
expression of all the proteins in our
panel and so you can see for example
here we have CD 19 so there's a DNA
labeled antibody there and there is the
fluorescent labeled antibody that was
used to sort the cells and we see very
strong expression in the b-cells and
almost no expression and the t-cells
same sort of result you know here we
have CD 3 where CD 3 is expressed in all
the t-cell populations and not in the
b-cell population so it's a great way to
get a lot of information about very
small numbers of cells
so that was protein alone we have of
course looked at RNA as well and so in
this experiment we were sorting cd4
positive er cd8 positive T cells we
started either [ __ ] either 5,000 or
15,000 cells and we did triplicate
conditions for each so this just shows
using principal component analysis which
is a great way to look at you know what
explains the variance in the data you
know is it I mean it could be fifteen
thousand verse five thousand cells for
example but it's not it is cd4 verse cd8
are they explained to the majority of
the variance there so you can also look
at a heat map where you're looking at
those proteins and RNAs but this is
looking at 770 genes and 30 proteins all
at the same time kind of hard to make
much sense of that but one of the nice
features of our system is we also have a
software called in solver and using the
advanced analysis component of that
software you're able to take the data
and analyze it in a lot more depth so
you can take all the RNA and protein
and then just limit your analysis the
genes and proteins related to t-cell
functions and that's an example here and
you can see again here's protein
expression changing down here between
the cd4 and cd8 this is an unbiased
clustering so again we see that the cd4
cells clustering separately than the cd8
very strong differences in that
clustering you can go in and look at the
TNF superfamily so there's a whole
variety of different sort of genes
functional gene sets and protein sets
that you can interrogate within these
cell populations again here we see
although we start to see an inter mixing
of the 55,000 and 15,000 cells we see
clearly again the cd4 s and the cd8
separating is a very very strong protein
response down here so taking those cells
this is another component of variance
analysis and here what we're looking at
is the correlations of RNAi on the y
axis and protein on the x axis or in
this case I toss so what we see is in
the cd4 cells we see an increase in both
RNA and protein expression so again
we're looking at RNA from the light
cells we're looking at protein
expression from protein expression on
the cell surface again for cd4s you
would expect it has increased protein
but also has increased RNA and then in T
5 he has an example where there's no
increase in the RNA expression between
the C fours and CD aids but there's a
huge increase in protein expression so
again looking at RNA or protein alone
really doesn't give you a full picture
in the biology and the regulatory
mechanisms going on with these cells
looking at both at the same time can
even very rare population to cells
you're able to really understand the
regulatory mechanisms going on here so
we've also done a number of other
experiments the populations of cell
types that we're looking at continues to
grow but this is a very simple
experiment just looking at protein
RNA analysis from 5000 either stimulated
or unstimulated t-cells and this is a
volcano plot here where we have full
change left to right on the x-axis and
then we have p-value on the Left axis
and it's the inverse log of that and so
these sorts of we see genes and proteins
here as well so we have the protein in
the genes and so these molecules are
very strongly different to Express from
both a protein from both a log chain a
full change in a p-value sir
and then we see those that are increased
expression of a simulation so a really
great example of how much data you can
get how you can quickly use the software
in fact and the analysis approach to
identify genes and proteins that are
differentially expressed from very rare
populations of cells so I just wanted to
bring up this one additional panel that
we're in the process of developing and
so this is a panel focused on autoimmune
disease and I wanted to show it because
I thought it might pair quite well with
the the protein assays particularly if
you're doing research and autoimmunity
so this is again a panel that's going to
be something on the order of 770 genes
we're developing in collaboration with
institut pasteur and the way that the
initial approach to creating the gene
set was actually to take all of these
different autoimmune diseases shown over
here you really can't see in the plot
there and look across all the G
was--it's and pick genes associated with
those G Wasson's so in that way we're
getting genes that are known genetically
to associate with the disease State and
then on top of that we've added
additional genes sort of more related to
just general immune response genes and
immune cell function so I think this is
going to be a great panel to couple with
protein panels that we have for your
research into autoimmune disease and
with that I'm going to turn it over to
dr. Karen Anderson who's going to talk
to us about the approaches she's taking
with this to look at antigen specific
t-cells Karen it's all yours thank you
so much
so what we have been interested in is
doing deeper immuno profiling of the of
antigen specific t-cells in particular
looking at markers of exhaustion along
the continuum of t-cell exhaustion
especially in the setting of chronic
antigenic stimulation with either tumor
with viruses and with that see if this
works
there has been a number of studies over
the years looking at antigen specific
exhaustion and exhaustion biomarkers
this was a classic study out of the
laboratory of Rafi Ahmed looking at
chronic L CMV infection and if you look
at this in the murine model of L CMV
infection you can you can see the the
induction of exhaustion and with
exhaustion of antigen specific t-cells
you can see up regulation of a number of
different inhibitory molecules both at
the RNA level and as well as at the
protein level and down regulation of
signaling components for intracellular
signature signaling components and and
ultimately with loss of cytokine
secretion with interferon gamma or with
TNF alpha as shown here so so under
chronic exhaustion of antigen specific
t-cells at day 30 you can see loss of
interferon gamma and TNF alpha secretion
you also have loss of self-renewal and
proliferative signals as well and this
happens more specifically under chronic
antigenic stimulation where is acute
infection you have maintenance of both
cytokine secretion and proliferative
potential in these cells and so
identifying some of the molecular
mechanisms underlying this has been
efforts of a number of different
laboratories and a tremendous amount of
research over the years in this study
coming out from the Ludvig Institute in
Lausanne has been looking at chronic
activation states of an antigen specific
t-cell exhaustion and in particular
looking at tumor specific t-cell
exhaustion and the peripheral blood
verses tumor infiltrating lymph nodes
and tumor infiltrating antigen specific
t-cells in particular for melanoma and
melon a specific t-cells so in this
study if you compare epstein-barr virus
specific antigen specific t-cells to
chronic CMV antigen specific t-cells to
melon a specific t-cells what you can
see is up regulation of a number of
different checkpoint inhibitors but what
you even see specific differences in the
blood versus infiltrating tumor
infiltrating lymph nodes of melon a
specific antigen specific t-cells both
with in particular with ctla-4 and also
with Tim 3 and other biomarkers of
exhaustion and and also biomarkers of
activation and so there is this
difference in this need really to
identify deep deeper profiling of the
level of antigen specific t-cell
exhaustion and that it may vary between
different sites within people as well as
with between different antigens and so
as the cd8 positive T cells certainly
are undergoing exhaustion they lose
effector functionality and it appears to
be a stepwise fashion if you're looking
at antigen and specific effector
functions versus memory cells versus
exhausted cell as you can see Stepway
loss of interferon gamma or TNF alpha
expression in chronic infection and also
in the development of this almost energy
like state in this difficulty and an
impairment of cytokine signaling in
these patients and so what this ends up
leading to is that there is this this
progression along this exhaustion
continuum of antigen specific T cell
certainly for cd8 positive T cells and
in this very nice review published about
two years ago
looks at at a number of different and
progressive loss of different biomarkers
of exhaustion including cytokine
secretion but also loss in fairly early
losses of cytotoxicity and the
progressive increase in expression of
inhibitory receptors and the loss of
proliferative potential in these antigen
specific t-cells and so we were
interested in particular at looking at a
number of these different biomarkers and
to do more deep profiling of antigen
specific t-cells but be able to do it in
a in a more rapid way rather than doing
isolating for RNA seek analysis or other
types of approaches so we were
interested in sorting antigen specific
t-cells and looking both at protein
profiling at RNA profiling and so what
the challenge is and the fundamental
challenge with many of these studies is
just simply the limitation in the
numbers of t-cells and in this case
we're looking at pre pre stimulation
frequencies are often less than 0.1% of
cd8 positive T cells so these are very
low frequency events within isolated
peripheral blood mononuclear cells and
so we were interested in in having
sensitive ways of being we'll be able to
look simultaneously about RNA and
protein expression and so what we did
was look at antigen specific T cells
that were specific to the influenza and
one protein in particular peptide
derived from influenza and one
restricted to HLA a2 and so we looked at
peripheral blood of healthy donors and
looked at both cd8 positive tetra-
and cd8 positive touch more positive
populations that underwent sort flow
facts specific flow sorting and then
nano string based immuno profiling both
on the protein level and on the RNA
level and to do this we were actually
measuring down to about 400 cd8 positive
T cells in each population and in this
these are these tetra positive
population well both populations really
underwent in vitro stimulation for a
short term in order to increase the
presort frequency of the antigen
specific t-cells and so as you can see
the there was an increased relative
amount of 4:1 BB C D 27 and a number of
other co stimulatory Co inhibitory
molecules as you would expect in
stimulated antigen specific t-cells
relative to stimulated but antigen
negative t-cells cd8 positive T cells
that were not stimulated with specific
peptide and in in comparison looking at
the RNA profile also obtained from
approximately the same number of antigen
specific T cells you can see elevated
levels for example of Grand Zone B or
perforin relative to the nonspecific cd8
positive population and so we can start
to do more deep levels of profiling of
these antigen specific T cells from
peripheral blood and potentially from
other sites and currently we are looking
at the differences between different
types of antigen specific T cells in
particular influenza versus chronic
viruses such as CMV or EBV within human
populations and then ultimately to more
tumor specific chronically energetically
stimulated T cell populations and I
think that tools such as these provide
the opportunity to to do that on a more
rapid integrated platform system to be
able to look in particular at protein
and at RNA simultaneously within small
numbers of T cells and I think that
wraps up our overall webinar and now we
welcome questions thank you thank you so
much dr. Anderson and dr. Heiner Feld
for your presentation
I'd like to now start the live
- in any portion of the webinar if you
have any questions audience members that
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button to answer as many as we have time
for so let's look at our questions now
from our audience members you're a great
audience today by the way are there any
issues are there issues of antibody
interferences with the multiplex protein
analysis yeah okay this is done you know
I'll take this one um so this is
something that we've looked at quite a
bit so with all of our assays that we
develop our multiplex protein assays we
do look at whether there's interference
and one of the ways we do that is if we
stain with the antibody individually or
we stain with the antibody antibody in
the context of all the other markers in
the panel we can see whether they hit a
body behaves differently when you have
other protein other antibodies in the
mixture which can happen and if that
does happen this is not a problem
necessarily but we would take that
antibody out try a different closed
label it and then test it
great thank you so much for our network
question is how have you Bella dated the
oligo tag antibodies to ensure
specificity and sensitivity for example
the RNA sure sure so they come similar
kind of approaches so with our
particularly that's lowly antibodies
that we use in these assays that we
talked about today so we compare it to
compare the results to flow cytometry
data I should say and I think I
mentioned before all of our antibodies
we don't make antibodies we buy them
from vendors we make that clone
information available most of these
antibodies are actually from bio legends
so they're very well validated we
actually have a tech note that we wrote
that describes the validation that we do
that is on our website so you can look
at that for more detail but again we're
starting with high quality antibodies
we're adding a DNA tag
and making sure that we get the same
responses biologically and otherwise and
we would expect to see first the gold
standard which is supposed to tell the
jury so that really gets that the
specificity the antibody as well as the
ability to see the same sorts of changes
again that we would see flow cytometry
thank you and I want to thank our
audience members for our wonderful
questions coming in do flow cytometry
and nana string anti-bodies block each
other
so that's that's also a good question
and it's certainly possible that they
can so this I think gets it really the
3d flow application where we're staying
with a fluorescently labeled antibodies
we need for sorting and the DNA labeling
of the bodies for quantitation on our
platform so we always check that we
certainly you know
recommend to our customers that they
check it before they start a study
particularly if they're working with
fluorescent antibodies that are
different than what others have used so
very simple way to check that is to
stain your cells but actually take
yourselves and split them into two tubes
stain them both with the fluorescent
stain in the body but in one of those
tubes at our DNA labeled antibodies do a
quick analytical cytometry experiment if
you get good fluorescence for your key
markers that you need to sort yourselves
even in the presence of our antibodies
you're in good shape
definitely the other hand adding our
antibodies knocks down the signal you
know that those two clones are not
compatible and that they're competing
for binding in that case either you
still have enough signal to detect it
and you can still sort it and you're
fine or if it knocks it down lower you
would then want to change the
fluorescent clone that you're using and
try one that binds to a different
epitope on the protein great thank you
dr. Hannah so how do you normalize and
and analyze multi-omics data like this
and what controls are used
sorry Karen I keep jumping in and taking
answers but uh feel free to chime in
um so we have all of our panels so at
the RNA level we have a whole set of
housekeeping genes that we use for
normalization in our software in solver
we have a variety of tools that can be
used to either use all the RNA or all
the protein to normalize or using
subsets of those so it really depends on
the study so at the protein level it's
common that we will normalize based on
what we call the Geo mean that sort of
like the average of all of the proteins
and used that to normalize across the
different samples however if you have a
marker and you look at the data that you
know doesn't vary much such as cd45 you
can just select that marker and
normalize based on that so the software
lets you do pretty much anything you
want and it really comes down to the
biology we do also have some negative
control antibodies that you don't
normalize with that are quite important
to understand what sort of background
staining you have in your in your
experiment and also chime in on this
there's also level of not just
normalization but comparison for
controls that are used regarding
biologic controls so there's certainly
the opportunity to do different control
populations so we've been looking at
testament positive versus negative C D
cd8 positive cells or cd4 positive cells
that can be done you you can look at
stimulated versus unstimulated luckily a
number of these populations have been
looked at in fairly deep molecular
profiling studies so that so that we
have an expectation about the levels of
t-cell exhaustion for example and
different levels of co stimulatory or Co
inhibitory biomarkers that are expected
within these within these individual
cellular subsets so those are also
built-in controls that can be used
readily for this on this platform
Thank You dr. Anderson I think you have
special hair so here's our next question
and again I want to thank audience
members we have some wonderful active
participation today did you analyze nano
stream data alongside the data from the
flow sort
so go ahead Karen all right I'll go
ahead yeah so we have done that I mean
there was a heat map I showed in the
talk where it showed essentially the
sorted populations which are obviously
positive for the marketers that were
interested in sorting on also show up
positive with the Nanna string data so
we have those sorts of easy and obvious
comparisons we also have of course to
look at we look at like mean
fluorescence intensity for the
populations if we're sorting partly to
make sure that our antibodies are not
interfering as we talked about before so
I guess those are the two main places
where we've really done sort of direct
comparisons of the flow sorting data
with the Nano string data that said you
know you've got both datasets in hand in
fact there are some examples of a
project that we're doing where where
there antibodies that we don't have in
our panel but that they're interested in
characterizing so they've added those to
the fluorescence cocktail they're not
sorting them those antibodies but
they're using those antibodies a
phenotype they're sorted population we
happen to have RNAs for those molecules
so now they get the flow data
the fluorescence data for those markers
that we don't have in the panel they get
our markers which are in our panel but
they also get the RNA for those markers
so you have sort of they're combining
all those data sets and in order to
understand actually it's another immune
cell exhausting project wonderful thank
you
our next question is what cell types can
be profiled with this assay
sure so another great question and so in
terms of the method itself right the
staining of ourselves with the
fluorescent antibody is analyzing with
the DNA barcodes essentially in yourself
to be characterized um that said there's
a significant caveat to that which is it
does depend on the content of our assay
so currently our assays vary t-cell
focus so sorting and analyzing different
populations of t-cells so it could be
against um you know T regs or antigen
specific t-cells that those sorts of
samples you're going to get a lot of
great information using our RNA and
protein content certainly we are excited
to develop more content to allow you to
look at other types of cells in fact you
know if you have cell populations that
you think this would be a great fit for
I mean you can see on your screen
there's the 3d flow at nano string comm
we would love to hear from you um so
that we can understand what are the best
what's the best content to develop great
thank you
our next question comes from across the
country how much diversity is present in
the antigen specific populations you
isolate well it depends on how you
measure diversity I mean there's
certainly the antigen specific diversity
and and the for example the T cell
receptor diversity can be quite high
whether or not there is more embedded
subtle differences in diversity in terms
of the different levels of antigen
specific exhaustion for example really
remains to be seen I think at this point
we've really only been looking at one
population so far we've been looking at
flu in one specific t-cell so I think
that it remains to be seen how much
individual diversity both between
antigen specific t-cells and then within
an antigen specific T cell populations
we can really look
I think one of the major limitations
especially if you're looking at
unstimulated populations is is precursor
frequency for that you'll need if you
start looking at sub subpopulations
within those cells you're looking at a
very limited number of cell populations
and that will be one of the limitations
of being able to drill down to two even
smaller numbers of subpopulations of
antigen specific t-cells thank you and
thank you both for answering all of
these wonderful questions coming in from
our audience we have time for a few more
questions here's our next one how long
does it take to run an assay well I
think that that depends on again the the
precursor cell frequencies the the
primary limitation in the time is the
time that required for doing the flow
sorting and it's actually quite similar
to what we would normally be doing for
flow sorting you have to prepare the
cells they have to be undergo an
antibody binding and and all of the pre
analytic preparation is required prior
to the flow sorting but the primary
amount of time really ends up being in
the time spent on the slowest order to
be able to collect those antigen
specific cells the amount of
manipulation after sorting is relatively
limited and then it it takes additional
time just to do the nano string assay as
well but it is fairly comparable up
until the time that they were running on
banana string machine it's it's
relatively comparable to doing routine
flow sorting for low frequency antigen
specific t-cells at least that we've
been doing thank you thank you dr.
Harrison dr. Hanna can add yeah okay a
little bit yeah I was just going to say
that some so one of the strategies
that's become really common I think that
Karen mentioned this earlier is doing a
negative selection prior to staining so
that you can reduce the flow time the
amount of time on this order so that
that's one piece
but from start to finish it is two days
so you're staining and sorting one day
you're immediately license ozone after
sorting you then take that lice material
which again contains your the protein
tags and the RNA hybridizing that
directly to our barcodes it's an
overnight hybridization at 65 degrees
the next morning it's loaded on the
encounter platform and that evening you
have your data and to just take that raw
data and import it into in solver
generate the north do the normalization
and just get a sense of you know the
results oftentimes people are doing that
the same day so the end of the second
day if not the beginning of the third
day so it's very quick and and is this
workflow compatible with fixed and
penalized cells for intracellular
protein analysis yeah that's that's a
great question and one that we get asked
a lot as I pointed out there we do have
an intracellular protein panel and you
can add custom content to that we've
done a little bit of experiments with
that I will say that there are some from
the protein side it's fairly
straightforward but the fixation
permeabilization does result in issues
on party side so there are some
modifications to the workflow that could
be used but certainly if that's
something that anyone's interested in we
would love to hear from you it's
something that again we've done a little
bit of experimentation on but if
someone's really excited about that
approach we could we could work to flush
that workflow out a little bit more
great thank you here's an interesting
question audience member wants to know
I'm interested in very rare cell types
how many cells do I need to start with
to have 5000 for analysis
yes it's just a numbers game right so it
really depends on you know the starting
population what the expected frequency
is you know you should have some
information about that expected
frequency going into the study either
from analytical cytometry or from the
literature once we know that frequency
then you have to ask the questions do I
need to do some negative selection to
enrich four populations before staining
certainly there are limitations to how
many cells you can stain so reducing the
cells you're not interested in prior to
staining is helpful yeah so it really
you know I guess it's simple math at the
end of the day just looking at the
frequency looking at the numbers of
cells you have to start with and then
sorting until you get those 5,000 cells
I would say that you know five thousand
is a pretty ideal situation to get some
of course you get great gherkin counts
even at lower amount RNA you know if
they're stimulated T cells or then even
less than cycles and we still get very
good data but certainly as you start
looking at those unstimulated T cells
that don't have a lot of RNA the closer
you can get up to a 5,000 the better
data you're going to get the data is not
totally lost if you have less cells but
you start to lose some sensitivity for
what might be some interesting markers
[Music]
thank you to both of you
we have time for two more questions from
our audience members our next one is do
antigen-specific t-cells changed during
culturally culturing and how do you
obtain a baseline reading for the invivo
biology well they certainly activate
with culturing they I mean the whole
point of doing either short or long term
in-vitro stimulation is to increase both
the number and the activation status of
androgen specific t-cells it it can
dramatically increase your pretest
frequency of these cells and so can
improve the ability to do T's and flow
sorting but it also can change the
the intracellular cytokine levels the
amount of strands I'm in perforin it can
change a number of different biomarkers
of those cells as they get activated in
vitro so ideally they would be tested
prior to activation status but they're
there it really depends on the numbers
and if the target is is to try to obtain
5,000 antigen specific t-cells depending
on the the numbers and frequencies
you're starting with will will impact
obviously the strategic design of the
experiment and I think that that's one
of the challenges and I think that's
also something we have the opportunity
to be able to measure in in a robust way
to look at what those changes are under
different types of in-vitro culturing
and conditions and systems thank you so
much dr. Anderson our last question that
we can do for today's webinar is comes
from an audience member how does this
compare to other RNA plus protein
technologies
Karrie minute take a stab at that I'll
let you go first yes okay you can chime
in from your experimental perspective so
right I guess the biggest difference is
really that it's integrated that it's
that same small small population of
cells that you're getting both the RNA
and protein data in the counter digital
right so it's really simple data to
analyze so the other approaches that
people oftentimes use is as I was saying
before high parameter flow cytometry or
site op analysis and that's going to
really allow you to phenotype and
functionally characterize your cells but
it's going to be disconnected from the
RNA data and we've seen the advantage of
adding both RNA and proteins so RNA
again you're gonna sort the cells people
often sort them into a mices buffer then
for sort of non ministering methods you
then to purify the RNA generate cDNA and
then go to PCR library construction and
then data analysis where is within ana
string approach we just slice them and
hybridize them to the probes and you
have really simple data the next day I
guess that would be my I sort of nano
string centric comment on that Karen I
don't know if you ever perspectives well
I think there's a lot of been a lot of
effort to in particular to develop and
validate RNA seek analysis for example
on as Laszlo as single-cell work and I
think that much of that is has been
developed and they've been a number of
really outstanding papers on this one of
the challenges is that if you're going
down to very few cells or even to single
cell work it starts to become both cost
and effective and in somewhat
computationally unwieldy and for many of
the biomarkers that were interested in
you know we don't necessarily need a
full profile of every RNA biomolecule
but rather a targeted set in
particular to look at you know levels of
t-cell exhaustion or in levels of
activation or t-cell activation or
checkpoint inhibitor or checkpoint
expression etc and so you don't
necessarily have to look at the entire
RNA profile for example and so I think
that that is one of the advantages and
that you're getting quantitative levels
that you can compare multiple different
sub fractions of cells fairly rapidly
and you can get data fairly quickly and
it doesn't require sort of deep
bioinformatics analysis and I think
that's that's one thing that makes it
much easier to do a higher throughput
analysis of relatively rare populations
anyway so I think there are a number of
different technologies that are out
there but at least this this allows you
to be able to look at and at both the
RNA least for targeted set of RNA
biomolecules as well as protein
biomolecules dr. Anderson dr. Heiner
field thank you so much for your
presentation today I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor nano
string technologies for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that out announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thanks
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye